I think there are two key components
there. First is uh knowing your asset
inventory which almost nobody knows. Uh
so that's actually one of the key
foundations of our platform is how do we
get you all of the assets that are your
digital footprint uh and then aligning
them to your businesses. So at the end
of the day the CISO is uh you know a
seale executive or a SVP level executive
that is reporting to the board and they
need to know the business of the
company. They need to know what are the
critical business units, which
applications are the most critical that
make money uh and what is the annual
revenue. So risk quantification does not
have to be a super complex PhD level,
you know, formula and stuff like that. A
lot of our customers at the beginning of
this journey, they just basically pencil
down, look, I'm I am a company that is a
billiond dollar company and I'm at a
high level. we have five business units
and we know each business unit makes
this much money and I know that these
assets are aligned with this business
unit these assets are aligned with this
business unit and you can start from
there and so the the key for any in um
risk management is value at risk so what
is your value at risk and if you don't
quite exactly know right now look if if
this attack happens I will lose 50
million 100 million a lot of our CESOS
in the initial part of the journey
actually they just start off by
penciling down the total revenue of that
particular business unit as a starting
point.
[Music]
Hey, Sumemed, welcome to 20-minute
leaders. Thank you so much for being
here. How are you? I'm doing well. Thank
you for having me. I'm looking forward
to this chat. Yeah, I'm really excited
for this chat. So, Sumed, you I think
you have a really interesting um job to
do because um I I get to speak with
CISOs and with company executives all
day long at this point and I get to hear
about their their challenges as they as
it comes to different cyber security
threats. And one of the things that we
know is challenging is that cyber
security is ever evolving. um
quantifying its risk is not trivial and
just over the last two years we've found
ourselves in an agentic era where
everything is changing old cyber
security mechanisms are changing new
ones are evolving and so I'm I'm
assuming that you have your work cut out
for you so it's going to be a fun
conversation before we get into that
tell me a little bit about yourself
you've been with Kalis for more than two
decades and so would really love to hear
about your journey
Yeah, thank you very much. Uh and yes,
those are really interesting
conversation. And I'm looking forward to
uh having those because uh cyber
security look I think we are in a a
world where um digital transformation is
accelerating at a pace we've never seen
before and it's enabling businesses is
enabling governments to provide uh you
know amazing capabilities to their
citizens which they were not able to do
in the past and so the the securing of
that infrastructure is super important
but also at the same time we have to
remember that cyber security is a
riskmanagement exercise and so uh
unfortunately we cannot just buy
anything and everything that pops up and
and try to uh to deploy it. We have to
look at it from a risk equation
perspective. So uh looking forward to
that conversation. I think a little bit
background for me. Yes, I I um I have
been in qualis for 21 years. I like to
say that uh sounds a little bit better
than two decades because decades sound a
little bit old but I feel like now I'm I
am legal at 21 in the United States.
Right. So it's there you go. Yeah,
that's a good point. Uh but but I joined
uh you know I of course I was born and
brought up in India and uh I I came to
the US and I worked originally for
Northwest Airlines reservation systems
and then um I I came to Qualis uh 21
years ago. I was one of the initial
software engineers that wrote the core
on our scanner that we had back then and
you know we were one of the crazy ones
to to think that we can deliver security
services on the internet which today of
course cloud is a fashion statement.
Everybody's cloud first, cloud fresh,
you know, cloud native. uh but we we
were really at the time pioneering in in
that and um from that I have had the
opportunity to really almost do every
single role at qualas that you could
imagine at a company and so I've done
product management u after engineering I
did customer support I need I did um
even uh IT uh but it really gave me a
really great perspective and then four
years ago after being uh chief product
officer for a while I got the
opportunity to take on the role of CEO
uh as a public of a public company in
cyber security and we've really created
a great brand. So I'm pretty happy about
uh the journey so far. So cool. And so
really it's a you know cyber security is
all about risk right? So walk walk me
through a little bit about how you how
you think about risk in the context of
cyber security. What is the role of risk
quantification? What role does it play
in the industry that we're in?
Look, I think today we have to separate
what is a little bit difficult from what
needs to be done, right? And uh and the
the role of quantification, I I almost
feel like that's the only role of uh
that you would have that is important in
cyber security because when you say
risk, what is the first question that
comes to mind? How much how big is the
risk? Right? And most people are today
not really able to quantify that or
haven't put the effort to quantify it
that way. uh uh because you know the
spend in cyber security for the last few
years has been as one of the CISOs I
talked to said that uh there was an open
bar and in the cyber security spend and
and now that has changed and you need to
get your ticket for your drink from your
CFO before you can move forward and uh
and so it goes down back to the question
of quantification uh risk quantification
is I think absolutely paramount in cyber
security because if you don't know how
much risk you have you don't quantify
that how can you know how much you
should spend on bringing that risk down?
Of course, right? If you have a $50,000
car and you're spending $50,000 to to
bring the risk down for that car, that's
not good business, right? So, any
business should be looking at well, how
much is my risk? How much do I stand to
lose in case there is a certain attack
uh and how much of that risk and like
with any risk there are sort of three
components, right? One is risk
mitigation. How much should I spend in
proactively mitigating the risk? risk
should never goes down to zero right you
should really not at some point there's
diminishing returns so how much risk can
I accept and then the third part is
whatever I cannot mitigate or accept I
need to transfer that risk to a cyber
insurance company so at a very high
level if you don't get too deep into the
excitement that vendors have about their
unique technology from a business from a
board and CEO and CFO level cyber
security is a risk management exercise
and it has to be grounded in
quantification yeah and So you know one
of the challenges I think of cyber
security is that you have so many
different parts of cyber security right
I mean effectively you have dozens of uh
of different postures that you have to
manage there's thousands of tools and so
what is qual's role within the cyber
security landscape in helping
organizations both understand where they
should be investing as well as actually
solving some of these end points
themselves.
Hey, you look I think risk management is
a ever evolving um uh journey, right?
because the the risks keep changing and
so you know at the beginning you were
just looking at maybe vulnerability
scanning and patching and then you have
then cloud security came about and now
with AI you have uh you know what you
guys are working on deep fakes and stuff
and uh which is by the way I had a crazy
experience where where one of my
employees was contacted on WhatsApp and
uh um you know that's typical they use
my picture and stuff like that asking to
spend money however this uh thread actor
proactively offered the employee a zoom
call and uh so you know the employee of
course being cyber security employee was
obviously caught on to it but he got on
the zoom call what the threat actor did
they took a video I had posted on
YouTube where I was speaking about
something and then played that video
through Zoom as if I was on the call but
the audio was muted so it was like hey
I'm having issues with audio let's just
go back to chatting on WhatsApp and can
you spend me send me a million dollars
right so the technology was just basic
social engineering things something you
could have even done 10 years ago but uh
today the question is well how much does
the company stand to lose if something
like that happens right and so anchoring
that is an ever evolving uh area of
saying well what are the new as new
digital um modes come about agentic AI
is coming about what is the new risk
that it is creating and by the way not
everything creates a major risk right
we've seen this with cell phone usage
when byod for mobile devices was a big
thing people were like, "Oh my god, this
is going to be so bad." It turns out in
the bigger picture of all the various uh
uh risks that you could have that was
not one of the major risk and so as a
company you constantly have to evaluate
the technology you're using, you have to
evaluate the the risk that that can
bring. And you know, so couple years
ago, cloud security was sexy and now AI
security is going to be top of mind. And
by the way, by the time we figure out AI
security, quantum's already knocking on
the door. So everybody's going to be
like, "Hey, what about quantum
security?" Right? So it's ever evolving.
So at Qual is what we really realized
and we like many vendors in the space
where like hey we we are going to have
the ultimate platform that is the one
platform that everybody can use and they
only need this one thing. Uh and I think
to be fair we have realized that in the
industry no CISO wants to you know go in
that direction. They want to empower
their team to pick the right solutions
for whatever that specific job is.
Whether it's security of containers,
whether it's security of cloud, but then
they want to be able to talk business
language. And business language is
money. It's about how much money do I
stand to lose if a particular attack
happens. And then by the way, based on
my current tooling, what is the
possibility of that attack happening? So
the conversation needs to be as an
example we have a $500 million a year
business unit. If there is a outage
created by cyber security we're going to
it's going to cost us 10 million a day
for 7 days. So that's 70 million. And by
the way based on the signals I'm getting
from my cloud security and my uh you
know on-prem security and all these
different identity everything. If I put
all of it together, I can come up with a
score that essentially is a proxy to say
if my score is 800 on a,000, that's
essentially saying the possibility of
losing that much money is about 80%. And
you want to bring that down to say an
acceptable 30%. And now you know exactly
the four things you need to do to do
that and how much it is going to cost.
So today the conversation for cyber
security leaders with the CFO is, hey,
give me $2 more million and I will make
it better. But they cannot explain how
much better. Now the conversation can be
by the way the the potential of losing
$70 million today is very high. Uh if I
spend $500,000 I can bring that risk
level down from 80 to 30. And so now the
CFO is that makes sense. Can I invest
$500,000 to reduce the possibility of
losing 70 million a day uh a week by
80%. Yes. So that's the conversation
that needs to have. And so call is we
introduced the concept of a risk
operations center. Everybody's been
using a a security operation center for
reactive threat detection. But what
about proactive risk management? And so
um instead of sort of trying to go and
replace all the tools the customer have,
we created a risk operation center that
feeds in from all the existing tools
that they have, provide risk
quantification, provide the ability to
aggregate uh findings, then provide a
way to um report on that. But most
importantly the most important thing in
cyber security is remediation. So now
provide a way to actually fix issues and
uh you know back in the day when we
started came up with the idea 5 years
ago of uh actually doing patch
management while doing vulnerability
management people thought we were crazy
to do that but just in 2024 qualis
agents deployed 110 million patches in
our customer environment in one year.
So, at the end of the day, I I always
say this, like you can spend $10 million
in building nice dashboards and taking
selfies with that, but if you didn't fix
the issue before the attacker comes, all
of that money was a waste. So, how do we
create a operations center that
operationalizes your risk management,
prioritizes the things that are actually
important, but not important because
they are hot and sexy. It's important
because it's going to impact your
business by a certain amount of money.
And then you focus on fixing those
first. And that's really what we are
been focusing on now with our enterprise
tour risk management platform and the
ability to provide board reporting using
a risk operation center.
Now I I have a you know I'm I'm
considering the conversation that the
CISO has with the CFO saying you know
we're going you know we're currently
vulnerable at a certain with certain
attack vectors and you know we've seen
the and and we have a perception that if
we don't do something about it we stand
to lose $70 million at a certain with
certain um percentage and if we do a
certain action we will reduce that. How
do you help the CISO translate this from
handwaving numbers that are abstract to
something quantifiable? Because a lot of
these threats are theoretical until they
become real, right? That's the nature of
the beast here. How do you then what do
you see CISOs doing or maybe that Qualis
is doing that it helps that helps
actually ground the conversation to be
much more practical and much more
tangible.
Yeah, I think there are two key
components there. First is uh knowing
your asset inventory which almost nobody
knows. Uh so that's actually one of the
key foundations of our platform is how
do we get you all of the assets that are
your digital footprint uh and then
aligning them to your businesses. So at
the end of the day the CISO is uh you
know a seale executive or a SVP level
executive that is reporting to the board
and they need to know the business of
the company. They need to know what are
the critical business units, which
applications are the most critical that
make money uh and what is the annual
revenue. So risk quantification does not
have to be a super complex PhD level,
you know, formula and stuff like that. A
lot of our customers at the beginning of
this journey, they just basically pencil
down, look, I'm I am a company that is a
billiond dollar company and I'm at a
high level. We have five business units
and we know each business unit makes
this much money and I know that these
assets are aligned with this business
unit. These assets are aligned with this
business unit and you can start from
there. And so the the key for any in
risk management is value at risk. So
what is your value at risk? And if you
don't quite exactly know right now look
if if this attack happens I will lose 50
million 100 million. A lot of our CESOs
in the initial part of the journey
actually they just start off by
penciling down the total revenue of that
particular business unit as a starting
point and then get better at working
with the team to say so as an example
qualis you know the way we report to the
board we have like 13 platforms globally
in different countries and each platform
we know has an annual cohort of
customers and those customers we know
how much annual revenue they make. So
the way we report is to say look here's
13 business units this is how much money
we make per business or per platform
every year and currently what is the
score and what you want to see is that
you you want to go from highest business
uh annual business unit revenue down to
the lowest but then you want the risk to
go inverse the risk score should be the
lowest risk score should be on the
highest value business unit right and
then each company based on their um
domain has to has to work to figure out
and this is an ev evolution this is a a
part that everybody's now working to
figure out but what is your possibility
of loss now I say this a lot is today uh
there is less and less of a concern from
uh uh in the way that the business
thinks from reputational damage because
when was the last time you change your
provider because they send you a letter
saying that your data might have been
compromised we don't so if we are not
changing our provider the prov providers
not feeling as much of a financial
burden from uh reputation. However, they
may be a significantly more concerned
about an outage that can be caused by a
cyber attack. Right? If a cyber attack
causes an outage, maybe somebody heard
of the crowd strike out and what that
caused. So, it may make sense. Right.
And and that could have been caused by a
cyber attack. Uh similarly, right? So,
the that is a big concern. So, you have
to decide as a company. Uh however if
you're in healthare you are more
concerned about the healthcare records
uh PII etc. Yeah, exactly. But uh if you
if it's you know otherwise today fines
and everything you know but what happens
is that people know that there is a
playbook if there is a compromise they
get mandian they it's all happening on
the side right you have a PR company and
everything but your business is
continuing you're continue to handle
transactions and stuff like that the
challenge comes when okay I I cannot
handle transactions for for a day like
that's really much more disastrous to
the business so every company has to
evolve to for the CESOS to start to
figure out but
at any company as a starting point like
it's not that difficult to to start with
quantification with some of the basics
because as executive you should know
what are the annual revenues from the
different business units and then start
to put pencil down some values but I
think as collaboration between cyber
cyber insurance companies and companies
like us and quantification companies
becomes more and more mature this
information can be available directly
through the platform where you can say
like hey I'm a financial company of this
size then we can say typically uh you
know the payout for cyber insurance uh
tends to be less than you know $20
million. So like a $20 million policy
can cover up to 92% of uh claims that
come out from a company of your size in
your area. So those are the points of
evolution. However, it is it is we
cannot continue to report vulnerability
counts and how many buckets open in the
cloud type findings to the board or to
the CFO. It doesn't mean anything. If
you go to them and say we have uh zero
trust, uh doesn't mean anything. If you
tell the CFO, we're going to implement
multiffactor authentication, it still
doesn't mean anything, right? All they
want to know, and we see this in the
boardroom, right? The CISO goes and
gives an update. We spent two years
implementing multiffactor
authentication. And you know, then the
board goes, okay, great. So, how much
safer are we? But that I cannot tell
you, right? So the CFO is thinking,
look, if I give you a billion dollars,
you're still not going to say we're
fully safe. So I'm just going to give
you $500,000 because the answer doesn't
change. So now it is how do we anchor
oursel because we cannot continue. There
is no open tap in like where every year
we just continue to spend 20 30% more in
cyber security which means that we have
to align the risk to how much uh to the
business and then decide based on that
how much to spend how much to spend in
tooling and how much to spend in your
cyber insurance. Absolutely. And that's
where we partnered with cyber insurance
to provide customers um with a uh
additional discount on their insurance
premium if they are able to showcase and
show a unified scoring mechanism uh uh
that basically tells the cyber insurance
company that you know that this risk
level is low. So these are all sort of
new pioneering areas and as you can see
this is not about some magic technology
that we have which is going to find the
malware in hidden inside a binary that
is loaded in memory and stuff like that.
I think those are all things that are
tactical. Of course the the evolution
needs to happen but at a business level
the the need to have uh risk
quantification and conversation around a
risk operations center uh is very
important. And the CISO should be able
to walk into a board meeting and say my
2025 cyber security strategy is not that
I'm going to implement encryption on my
desk. It has to be we are going to
implement a risk operations center where
we can fully operationalize our risk,
collect assets and uh findings from all
different tools. actually figure out
what we don't need to fix because many
companies are spending time fixing
things that do not have an impact to the
business which is wasted uh innovation
which is wasted time from development
team I mean these code scanners as an
example these code scanners that do
static code analysis will throw you
millions of findings but like maybe only
1% of those actually cause risk if you
have your developers spend so much time
fixing that so how do you anchor that to
risk and and that's why we are so
excited about where we are going with
this journey Because now the
conversation is not hey you have to
replace your tool with uh what we have.
It is really about how can I provide you
a visibility across the tools that your
team already likes but then anchor it
into what is a real risk to the business
and and what is a dollar value risk. I
love it. So Med before we wrap up what
what is the the biggest advice that you
would give to cyber security founders
and entrepreneurs today as the space is
heating up is changing all the time risk
is evolving qual is evolving h what is
the biggest advice you would give
them you know as a as a product leader
for so many years the one thing that I
have learned is you really need to
listen to your customers and what is the
challenge that they are trying to solve
and you might have some absolutely
amazing
technology, but if it doesn't solve a
customer challenge that that they uh uh
that they really need to focus on, then
it is not going to be something that's
going to be widespread. And so the two
things I tell uh founders when they look
at is to say target for ubiquity like
find the solution that's going to be
needed by everybody. And so when I say
well who needs risk quantification
literally everybody that is actually in
cyber security, right? You need to
quantify your risk because that's the
definition of risk. you have to quantify
it. Uh so so that is something that I
tell people to focus on is can you
create something that can be ubiquitous
and then the second thing is anchor
yourself in the outcome for the
customer. So I know people are excited
today about AI and all of that but at
the end of the day the the the customer
doesn't necessarily care whether you're
using AI or you're using u you know the
thousand camels or whatever you know to
do the work. It is at the end of the day
they're looking for an outcome in which
is uh which is accurate which is fast
and which is cost effective and it just
so happens that the particular
technology can be uh helpful to them. So
don't focus too much on the technology
focus what the technology can achieve as
an outcome for a customer uh and that is
what is going to make you successful.
Incredible. Thank you so much. I really
appreciate your time your energy. This
was a great conversation and I very much
enjoyed it myself and I and I'm sure
there are many others listening as well.
So, thank you so much for being here.
Thank you very much. It was a pleasure
and I appreciate you having me on the
podcast. Thank you.